[Music]
Hey welcome back to our channel so today
we decided to do the boyfriend tag but
we're calling it beyonce tag we've
upgraded yeah we operating and we're
about to upgrade again to husband and
wife so we figured a wedding coming up
might as well do the boyfriend tag now
yeah you guys have been asking us to do
this video for a long time so finally
we're doing it and then we decided to
make it a little bit more romantic so we
got wine glasses and we also have a
bottle of wine that we bought when we
went to France
exactly no bar go back there yeah
prepping for friends so pour that wine
rivet and we're about to get a little
tipsy
cheers to a good cause the taste like
France
pretty soon we're gonna be drinking in
France and France on our wedding day are
you nervous no not really
you know what we've been planning for so
long now that it's like it's numbed my
excitement to it thank you so long for
you because usually couples planned for
about an entire year but we didn't start
planning okay no I'm you airy February
less than half a year but it's been such
a rush of planning that it's like numbed
the excitement I was excited to put it
back in like January February I was
excited year ago when I proposed to you
but now it's kind of like I'm ready to
be married I'm ready to get into my
married life and keep trucking along oh
you're ready to be tied down forever
with me yes yes
all right you're like I'm tied down to
you all right now you're just missing
the ring and I reckon Orly I need a
match this hand understand I don't know
I don't worry I have a worm ring yet so
I don't know if I really really left
left left yeah
what's your art exactly upset like and
you join my other side you're far away
from my heart look at this are you drunk
already baby radius of beating you know
we're into weekend with physical values
the first glass
I'm okay I'm good I'm good all right
before we begin this video is brought to
you by audible Thank You honorable in
you so audible is an online service
where you can listen to audio books and
podcast and any other type of
entertainment I've been listening to the
five love languages by Gary Chapman and
I learned that my love language is
quality time oh yeah
like right now yeah the green that I
honestly love the fact that now
audiobooks is a thing that's like really
popular because back in the day you have
to read like paper books and I always
fall asleep when I read books I don't
know why I think I'm not destined to be
a book reader but ever since I started
to do the audio voice I'm like hey I can
actually learn to love to read by
listening so you've been listening
something I've been listening to a book
by Robert McKee story for me I'm like
really into filmmaking and writing and
screenwriting and stuff like that and so
obviously I picked the greatest Rhian
writing book of all time story about
Robert McKee and actually once at
seminar for two so I feel really in tune
with its writing right now how do you
like listening to it rather than reading
it it's easier to pick up on the
information just because for some reason
for me when I read I end up reading the
same line over and over and over again
to try and understand it Brad and I
listen to it I kind of pick it up a lot
faster upon hearing it so maybe it's
because the big guy reading the book
they're just better at creating context
for the story everyone liked the choice
of time yeah just when I read it like
super monotone yes like what's the
context I don't know
read it again yeah so you guys can get
your own free 30-day trial audible.com
slash hit end case and make sure to
click on the link in the description
below we'll be there for you as well and
cheers for that Thank You Abed alright
now let's get started question number
one or the first question where did we
meet you answers and then I'll answer
and then we'll
what our answers are like why don't we
just see what I had to drill I have to
come down
oh look easy clutch all right hi we met
troubadours yeah the door that's where
we officially said hello nice to meet
you just like this like robot no it
wasn't like that
no I remember I first saw you you're on
the stage about to film Lex's show I was
like one of my first 21 and over show I
was like excited I'm like cool what is
this all about
and then I see you on the stage at that
point I had to rate we had already
became Facebook friends we met on
Facebook yeah like McLean we met on
Facebook yeah that's how we suspect
Troubadour next question where was our
first date I don't remember the name of
the restaurant scream ice cubes Korean
Barbossa we okay that was hurt I know
our first date is kind of weird because
we had our first like unofficial day
when we went o to show at El Rey and we
got to hang out backstage that was
pretty cool that was now of my first
date yeah cuz I was I joined that date
as like a platonic friend like nothing
romancing happening because which is you
and me and have anyone and everyone you
could have [ __ ] me ask to go to the
show with you ask me and I took that as
oh no I'm a guy that's what guys they
know but it's all like frustrating I
guess a little bit because I remember
telling you in the car on the way to the
show it just got out of a really serious
relationship I'm not trying to do it at
all I just felt like talking to you like
you're my friend
right not like potential lover because I
did not think of you that way at all
and then later that night we're
backstage looking at the show like to
the side and we're all like yay like
just going with this with the music and
then you decide to be slick who goes
behind me put this arms around my waist
and I'm like hey like I don't we talk
about this as a car minute what happened
to the respect dialogic
I know I like this kind no it's
dialogic riders show I took you
backstage it's just us to look
everywhere anyone could ask me dialogic
said you're into me didn't like you that
eventually I was I admitted to myself
that I didn't have a crush on you
because I thought in that moment I was
like nope nothing Tiffany focus on
yourself not gain another relationship I
only had to say that to yourself so many
times because you were just trying to
fight off I was wired right I'm being
honest I was I couldn't see past that
so anyways moving on to the next
question what was your first impression
of me uh first impression I think oh so
you mean you need some pictures just
impression chicks all right my first
impression of you was what a hot her
Magian girl we thought our meeting yeah
Oh heavy so we didn't meet at troubadour
at the show and we did talk on Facebook
for some time but I first laid eyes on
you at I don't know what bar it was that
was another bar it was another actor
body I presume that's the vibe room yeah
after party and asked my first laid eyes
on you and that night I was thinking
what a hot horny you girl you are and I
felt I went head over heels for you head
over heels yeah
yeah we know my first impression of you
was this guy needs a shower yeah there's
really long scruffy greasy hair and look
when you have intelligent hair it was
greasy and it can nappy like okay the
shower
Wai ghin tepee I don't know that's how
that the attraction was that strong
again we're done with my game ones and
now and a bad person that know bad
hygiene long hair I would say back at
all Open Sesame
it's destiny thanks to destiny we are
together because everything we're
working against you honestly because the
first time I went to his apartment it
was it oh my god it looks like a dump
all of his ex-girlfriend's stuff with
everyone in your apartment it look like
you still live there this is how you
prep to have a girl come over and you so
diamond from us don't you know the rope
or dope method of picking up girls I
just wanted to make a hard for myself
test my game you know you were trying at
all anger lucky I somehow looked at all
right when did you meet the family
oh I'm hard okay well in terms of
meeting your dad we actually vlog this
schedule is recorded memories that was
actually last year almost exactly a year
ago we went to Mexico and we met your
dad and your dad side of family in terms
of your mom Alonzo Harbor one caddy
remember I would get to mate sometime in
September of 2012 did you start seeing
each other in May 2012 and then I don't
think we like really took our
relationships super seriously until the
pepper that's when I think you started
inviting me over to more families
things maybe Silas who do not remember
at all and then I remember meeting your
parents when they came over to visit and
then we all went to go eat Korean food
no pressure no breakfast food was with
Isaac I'm talking about when I saw that
when Isaac in my hair yeah I don't know
for me when I met your parents we have
to go eat live octopus right hell I'm in
life lobstering live everything you
would create everything came out moving
yeah wishing Susan adventurous I don't
know I felt like they were kind of
testing me feel like really testing you
to see how is interesting I mean they
were testing themselves to all testify
so I like this crazy
I had never dated outside of my panic
bubble so I didn't know if this was like
some sort of like Asian kind of test of
like let's see what's how like all the
crazy things you can eat without
literally now some down to try anything
at least once but are you down and
trying chicken feet I have tried on
before remember you took me to Dallas
and we tried it don't ya see I'm down to
try it once but if I don't like it don't
expect me to ever try again yeah anyways
next question we like to ramble on
ramble on we do next question do I have
any weird weird obsession I mean I don't
known as a beard but I know an obsession
of yours is watching movie trailers
Idaho weird obsession oh man I am yeah
you're like strangely obsessed with
movie tricks everything will tell me or
the movie theater and watch a movie
you know like wait trailers before the
movie a movie speed is way back here
right she does it
things like this and then I'm like dude
big bag like relax like it's hindering
my experience to watch the trailers so I
can keep the controllers but if it's
like Michael Bay or like transformers
I'll stay back here if it's passengers
I'll stay back here favorites
Christopher Nolan dumper coming up Oh
Dunkirk stinky Orbitz Quentin Tarantino
who would orginal does not believe it
you scoot your whole butt and figure out
the edge of the seat I think you're just
like this how good it is
on the edge of my seat literally yes
your little obsession is cute I like it
it shows your passion which is a turn-on
for me I like seeing your passion what
about me
yeah we're decisions you have a weird
obsession for small things yeah tiny
things but there's a key factor to my
obsession you have to find it on your
own terms because I show you a lot of
small thing oh thank you
oh that's not true that was true I
where's Isaac Isis not here right now
but Isaac would vouch for me serious I
just like it doesn't work sometimes
mommy doesn't always find everything
small that's cute it's because you don't
understand that one criterion of mine
that makes me freak out what's the
criteria so it needs to be something
that small that is functional it can't
just be like a little toy train it's
like okay cool like the toy train do
carrots but it is like the toy train
that actually has like an entire like
steam engine you see the scene to my
eyes like legit like actual tiny little
train that is supposed to work the same
way as the big ones and that's when I
freaked out like whenever I feel is
painting some kitchen videos and there
are even entire Joel and everything so
many I'm like oh my god I was that
possible
I don't know why I'm so expensive I
don't even understand my own discussion
with anything
it's so weird this is what's the feeling
yeah you just want to like squeeze me no
like an easy baby cute little babies
when squeeze the cheeks or like you see
a little puppy you want to hug it is
this that kind of like honest overload
feeling or what is it no I think the the
emotion I feel is just shrieking like
it's just like oh my god it's so cute
I don't want to like touch it or destroy
it pinch it or I don't want to do any of
that I guess I would want to do court it
could you know like when once you see
the mcusic all my father would just kill
it so be really closely I could die like
death and destruction yeah so we're at
yeah I don't know movie trailers and
tiny penis mm-hmm next question how long
have we been together
Alan BB is it that's a test for you guys
how long you been together
not like did you know the answer go
straight to what five years yeah okay
we were waiting for so long today like
am I gonna get five years next question
all right next question do you have a
tradition with your boyfriend uh weird
tradition we don't have them doing well
I mean I can't think of another
tradition but I know one that we broke
which was Tiffany's every Christmas oh
she forced me to break that tradition I
didn't want to I was trying to honor our
relationship so much and with Tiffany's
every year I'm not like you know I'm not
that kind of garlic I literally don't
own anything designer I'm like I'm not
materialistic at all I try to thrift
shop for all of my clothes in my shoes
and any accessories that I have like I'm
totally not name-brand at all so I do
appreciate that you gave me my first
ever name-brand jewelry I'm like I'm not
that I maintenance like that we are not
yet you're super the next question what
was our first road trip was it TJ or was
it up to her stylist to fix her I feel
like T James first GJ's we went to
Tijuana to go visit my family and we
went to work dawn we're wiping skulls
and that's where we got some really ball
monster and then we just hung out with
my aunt and my cousin Jenny
yeah that's the first time I met anyone
from your family yeah we I think we're
dating really it's really early on yeah
that trip specifically I felt like how
is the disposable boyfriend and rest
time yeah just it's so new I was like I
don't know how many people over again
you know
I don't know how long we're gonna last
it's just like and the road trip is fun
you know meet new people eat some good
food and good memory so now last time
was the next goes more like kind of
really put on the big boy pants now it
has done a good impression and make sure
that everyone likes me here well you did
a really good job with my aunt because
she loved you till his date she's like
that boyfriend of yours is amazing don't
ever let him go
she was comparing you to the previous
one that she was like they were garbage
for it and then so is a bar higher bar
next question what was the first thing
you notice about
jawline i next thanks so that's what is
my favorite restaurant Oh what daughter
just watch TV do you even know you don't
know I'm like me and food is like we
don't have the greatest relationship
I only two survivors don't really have
like a favorite like oh I could dive it
okay no actually I didn't 100 that's two
blues I love it every time I think about
it and go crazy for it and it's kind of
a tradition of ours now I'm stirring our
words along I'm going to me
cheers Cheers I know what it is how is
it sherbet yeah so that is actually a
traditional horse every time something
exciting is happening or we want to
celebrate we ordered sugar fish to be
delivered to our home because they have
it really cool like Japanese bento box
looking things but it's like all like
new sounds now I hold still a bad boy oh
yeah
because the best sushi I've ever had
it's the best if you have ever in LA you
just have to have to have to try sugar
fish one because this is the novelty
about your fish it's fresh fish cold
served on top of fresh rice which is
and they play on the temperature thing
is no other restaurant I've ever been to
where they plan on temperatures they
definitely want you to eat a sushi was
in like minutes of it coming up or I'll
still lose out on that novelty of the
temperatures which we do because if you
order it to come to our home that's true
so do this on that but recycle of the
temperature thing the fish itself is
only sold buttery and like yeah so
that's my favorite restaurant with your
here yeah that's right oh right yeah
ah your favorite restaurant and you like
so many different conditions I'm trying
to figure out what my favorite ride
golden jelly huh sure I can't pick up
one right now as a good one okay I mean
the ones I know you let goals in Delhi
JJ's uh all of that does please what the
[ __ ]
Oh family might be my favorite would
actually family and will depict an was
barbecue they have like paint like the
Ducks hanging this kind of my favorite
can't get enough of that so yeah not
your favorite I know
next question what do we argue about the
most I would say it is communication
yeah that's a very recurrent argument of
ours I always ask comes to communicate
let me know what's happening let me be a
part of your life and because I do the
same to him so whenever you don't
communicate and I find out like
something to our friends and I'm like
you didn't tell me like what I'm not
like PFF here what happened here might
be affected I think I should be person
I'm a very introverted person and a lot
of things out that's why you should feed
me more of this stuff on the regular
you're opening up that amount of air
getting a little tipsy are you opening
up a little bit not are you know Joe's
foods no I you are it's so messy just
lost a wife I'm trying to air it all
right you know how you're supposed to
drink
enjoy so Aaron Spelling just jump and at
the tables not even uh-huh landing on
the table yeah I think we argue about
communication of modes if you really
want to further define and actually
we're arguing about my inability to
communication to India yeah what would
your answer be I guess it is not
communication what do we argue about I
don't know I don't I don't argue you
argue because you end up yelling at me
for something yeah just me hang I found
like the most pickiest girlfriend ever
no you're not I feel like it's really
normal to add thing everyone can relate
to dislike the moment you had been with
someone for X amount of time or you
moved in with them and you get you know
cabin fever with them it's super normal
to like get into arguments and you know
get fed up with each other and your
tempers get shorter and shorter over
time identically normal and what's not
normal is to not have anything against
you and not argue about anything is I
don't have that's why I'm like with I
mean you're perfect
ah you're totally not perfect sure
because I always tell you do I'm like
can you tell me what's wrong with me cuz
you never complained about anything
about me ll ever there's nothing to
complain about there is just stop it
you're looking at me with loving eyes
you like to keep the house clean you do
good job with Isaac you don't cook you
can complain about that all day no as
often you get out of my way the
kitchen's right so is good
does per day per game do the laundry I
don't know you did
I don't remember something about when I
watch when I want to watch movies you're
there to watch movies with me so you're
not inhibiting with that you make videos
together we do everything we drink
together cheers to that
cheers to us
perfect a complaint or I'm dreaming this
two more always self because I don't
like the taste of alcohol this wine
tastes good we first are geniuses and
the more you drink the more you to do
all my fake eyelashes up
I like that me thank you okay get rid of
it it's like my nose kind of just this
pin right here
I can't okay next question who wears the
pants in the relationship
I guess you wear the pants no idea where
the man oh good good what you can you
wear the pants I think I do and I didn't
want that to be the answer because you
should wear the pants
yeah I know I feel like I do in advance
know what we got what makes me be
attached to get over the fences where
there because you always ask me for
permission for everything it feels like
you're saying hey mom can I go do this
can I wear this can I eat this can i
watch the vid and I'm just like I don't
know live your life just to communicate
with me you're communicating no good
you're a skate that's different though I
was like if you say no then I'm not
doing it I don't like that that's still
controlling I want to be that
controlling person in your life like no
I wear the pants I'm a great reader and
every great leader has a great second in
demand and I like to ask my
second-in-command for their opinion oh
and I like the way the opinions out real
quick before I make a decision okay that
sounds better
alright next question what is my
favorite Munich Helles best musical with
Camilla I think music in Frenchmen
French
[Music]
música is that musica musica musica
you